if I were to give you one word to
describe this experience it would be
galactic this year just goes beyond any
boundaries that you think you have in
your life you push yourself you are
pushed by other people and you grow
exponentially in places that you never
expected to way bigger than you ever
could've imagined I would say magical
because there's so many experiences I've
had that have moved me in terms of how
I've thought emotionally intellectually
I've been overwhelmed just by all the
experience that I've had and they've
been so positive that I just think
they're magical I want to give you two
words life changed it opened the door to
new opportunities that I haven't seen
before coming to Stanford also it had
the impact of changing my perception of
different fields and of the human nature
in management and in business
transformational what I thought I was
going to be doing after a year when I
started this program and what I'm
looking at doing is something that I
would never have imagined one year ago
experience as in once-in-a-lifetime
experience
one word to describe my experience for
the last year would be the word
inspiring I think this year has just
opened up my eyes to so many different
cultures ways of thinking new people and
opportunity and it's something I'll be
grateful for for the rest of my life
you